[MUSIC PLAYING]
As an app developer, the
biggest problem you have
is how can I show my
wonderful creation
to every user possible.
And this isn't as
straightforward
as tell your friends.
Users today are informed
and use different channels
to find, understand,
and get apps.
Did you know that
three out of four users
do some kind of research
before installing an app?
Among all of those
informed users,
how do you attract new,
interested users that
will generate revenue for you?
You don't just want
a ton of users.
You want a ton of users
who love your app.
So how do you wade
through the herds
of less-than-interesting
users for the ones
that truly matter for you?
Here are three
recommended methods.
To attract new users, you could
run an app install campaign
on Google search.
These ads will be shown just to
users who don't have your app.
To find the users
that are potentially
most interested in your app,
use installed app category.
It can find new customers who
have already installed apps
from related categories in
Google Play Store or the App
Store.
And to find high-value users,
use paid users targeting.
It enables you to show ads to
app users who have previously
made purchases.
For Android, you
could also show ads
to only those users who
have made an in-app purchase
within a certain category.
In order to use this
tool effectively,
you need to understand these
terms, average revenue per user
and lifetime value.
Why?
Because you can't manage
what you can't measure.
Average revenue per
user-- ARPU, if you
wish to sound like a
pro-- is a simple ratio
that divides the revenue by
the number of users in a time
period.
It gives you additional
insight into how your campaign
is really performing.
It's not rocket science.
If revenue goes up
and ARPU goes down,
you're not attracting
users that spend.
Not so good.
If revenue goes up
and ARPU goes up,
you are making more
money out of your users.
Good.
Besides average
revenue per users,
there's another handy metric
called lifetime value, or LTV,
which is a new report in
Google Analytics for apps.
It allows you to understand
the value of your users
to your business.
Rather than looking at
an isolated session data,
you can instead look
at the ongoing impact
users have from the
date of acquisition
and through the rest
of their activity.
Lifetime value is
especially important
if you're running a user
acquisition campaign.
Your acquisition cost
per user is should not
exceed the user lifetime value.
So what happens when you combine
average revenue per users,
lifetime value, and our new API?
Well, a developer
GREE tried just that,
and ended up seeing
five times improvement
to their monetization.
Excellent.
[CHEERING]
On the next episode, we will
see how to make money in games.
Cool?
Until next time,
eat your vegetables,
increase your users
lifetime value,
and listen to your partner.
[MUSIC PLAYING]